we're joined today by incredible guest
Alex Boyer a magician a very cool person
a man with impeccable hair I called him
here for a couple reasons one we love
magic two the world of visual effects
and special effects in my opinion is
kind of like an offshoot of this tree of
Illusion right magic is like the
original visual effect it's the original
special effect it's that original trick
that blows your mind and takes you
somewhere where you've never been before
and I'd love to learn what a magician
can teach us from The World of Magic to
the world of filmmaking and visual
effects I think it's all about the story
visual effects you know if it's just an
effect or an explosion or something like
that's it's not going to sell anything
you need a story you need I think you
need to care about something around that
you know a story can exist just within a
single shot within a single frame but
before you do any of that there's a
problem there's there's this change in
Ren pfxrs react you know throw up a cool
shot he's like whoa yeah but he's seen
it all nothing Sparks him anymore I need
to rekindle that fire inside of I need
to I need to blow his mind so maybe if
we make it real okay we can download
that all right yeah this is it hey Ren
you okay buddy hey I have somebody here
I'd like you to meet this is this Alex
Boyer Hey man nice to meet you what's up
what's up I've seen a lot of magic
before yeah I know all the tricks okay
well uh let's try something here uh
regular deck of cards you can check it
out if you want we can Shuffle it also
okay okay wait go classic trick here
okay all right all right okay it's not a
fake deck of cards no it's a regular
deck all the cards are different
actually I'm just gonna go right in the
middle between you guys and I want you
to see one card when I go like this but
make sure it's not this one right okay
ready
going
yes I did get one is it a red card it is
not a red card okay cool I want you to
look at Nico's eyes and try to transmit
the card you just saw in the deck right
so look at him in the eyes
I think you can do it go like this with
your finger and just take a card yeah go
ahead yeah take it place it against you
and make sure nobody no against you yeah
okay offward we're gonna cut down
so there's only one person in the entire
world that knows the card that you saw
right and it's you it's you it's me and
no one else for the first time
and then the card you saw
there's a five of clubs five of clubs
are you 100 sure yeah
yeah
I actually legitimately didn't think
he'd actually get that I was like
there's no way I'm gonna say a card
you're gonna get it wrong this first
trick in this whole video is gonna go
busting
that okay
thanks man
Alex thank you no problem thank you
would you be willing to show the crew
something absolutely absolutely I love
it let's see the crew and build their
minds
I remember thinking I don't I don't
Magic
did nobody say magic I hear there's a
wizard in the office this is Alex by the
way everybody we're filming yes
um I don't know if this experiment is
going to work uh but before I came here
actually I put one card in my wallet all
right so it's gonna act as a prediction
right let's try this um can you say stop
for me please go ahead stop here great
this is gonna be your card you can
remember it show it to everyone show did
the camera as well perfect uh can you
hold the deck for me for a second thank
you so much by the way they're all
different make sure they're all
different okay yep they're all different
this looks like a deck of cards to me
they're all different so it would be
amazing if the card you pick is the same
card I have in my wallet that would be
miraculous yeah nothing in my hand right
for the first time during a card over go
ahead show you yep yep King of Clubs
there's no way it could be in my wallet
you guys if you guys are gonna you
haven't touched that wallet yet
no move
all right 10 clubs
[Music]
no but I told you guys I actually it
doesn't look like one card
[Applause]
[Music]
what the heck
there's so many of them
that's it
we're done what's your name yeah Alex
nice to meet you a fellow Canadian
you know what pick any card for me
okay all right sounds good show to the
camera
and the crew as well I'm just gonna
place your card let's say right here
um can you go like this for me great
we're gonna put the deck right here and
your Adriana on top so my goal is when I
snap my fingers your card is going to
jump on top okay ready for this yeah
now move don't move don't move she's
gonna take the top card you think this
is your card
no it's actually a subscribe
[Applause]
I'm gonna take the card and make
Advantage just like that and we're never
going to see it again all right
that's a freebie for you guys uh but
seriously though if I snap don't move
your car jumped back
hopefully to the top just like this
but you know what remember when I made a
card vanish that was kind of like so-so
you know how about I make all the cards
in your hand vanish instead just like
that there's no way I see the colors
[Applause]
I was literally in the middle of saying
I see the cards behind
what
[Laughter]
so what's your secret to actually
guiding someone's eye you know because
that's what I feel it really comes down
to is the misdirection
if I take the ring and place it uh you
know what I'm in my hand right here
right sounds good so I'm just gonna take
the ring and place it here right
um and I was gone right so yeah
misdirection right so I'm conditioning
your brain to watch here all the time
and your brain knows that during is
going to be there right so when I do it
again your brain is like okay I get it
the ring is in this hand but in reality
it's in the other end right it's like a
pattern recognition yeah yeah it's like
it's a pattern here's the result here's
the result here's the result and then
your brain's gonna be like okay whatever
that's the result and you're like it's
like exactly change it it's like that
shot in contact when she's running into
the house and opens the mirror with the
medicine cabinet and it goes through oh
good she's running she's running she's
running and it's like okay they're
conditioning you it's just a steady cam
shot tracking her she's running and then
when suddenly like she enters the frame
and pulls out of the mirror it just
changed that pattern on you and you know
what I've I've watched this like maybe
20 times and I'm still just like mind
blown to it yeah it's a beautiful shot
um okay let's try something else here
um
uh Nico fix someone oh hey this one this
Jordan yeah
oh gosh okay hopefully this is gonna
work
[Music]
show me and the camera as well that's a
good pick there's no way there's no way
well you know what this is a trick with
both of you so uh join uh just a stop
for me anywhere stop here ready this is
gonna be yours all right and it's on
that kind of a trig right so it doesn't
matter if I see the guard so just show
himself nine o'clock it's great and
exactly Spades
um we're gonna go with you please turn
like this and Jordan place your audience
on top just like that all right
cute beautiful music now okay
um Jack of Spades I'm just gonna place
it right here place around on top like
that make sure I can't yeah okay Jack
right hopefully this is gonna work a lot
of clubs check the Spades watch one
there's no way
did you feel something no no
okay look in your hand stop it
what is real what is it what is this
that's crazy oh my gosh I feel different
film has a lot of tricks in it right
right what can we learn from from you
from magicians from the World Imagine
you know what what I miss is practical
effects sometimes I think maybe VFX are
just like too perfect and in Magic
there's a rule of when it's so perfect
it's not good right when it's too
impossible like people know it's fake
right so I like to pick your you guys
brain a little bit
um maybe try and figure out how we did
some of the stuff we did on TV for every
episode we had this crazy big Hollywood
trick that was shot only with one camera
okay and no cuts no nothing one
continuous shot and it's all practical
okay no effects no editing no nothing
nothing I want to know if you guys can
actually spot and maybe figure out how
we did some of these tricks
[Music]
got the dudes and some portable potties
all right you each go in oh is this
gonna be like the the swapping cards
thing
uh
oh wow
okay hold up I think the obvious first
answer is that you dug some holes in
tunnels and you just like climbed down
and walked across but you said there was
no Cuts you know magic should always be
safe I mean same thing with stunts right
you want to be able to continue doing it
for a long time and if you're always
rolling the dice at some point you're
going to roll a one you guys have to get
out of those porta potties and you have
to do so in a way that like people can
see you so when they trigger the car to
fall you guys are 100 clear
then you have to then get back into the
fourth porta potty so with all that in
mind you got marks in your cat you're
gonna practice you can get everything
figured out and your camera's gonna hit
a mark your cameras can hit a mark you
know exactly what your perspective is
and what those porta potties are
blocking I imagine you guys just got
that Mark figured out basically drew the
lanes and then walked out the door in
the back of the porta potties into the
junk moved back and then just walked
back in after they dropped the car
oh okay so you were right with the
perspective thing there's there's some
sort of perspective thing going on so
the thing is that the trash in the back
are exactly placed between the porta
potty right so when we go out you're
going to see that in a second by the way
the thing on the right there is a huge
metal wall just to protect us like you
said to make sure we're gonna be fine
and safe and with the camera pushing
push all the gaps in the car
blurred dude that's what I was looking
dude Nico you nailed it you guessed it
exactly yeah good job buddy thank you
good job I think when people have a bit
more knowledge and VFX or magic they can
appreciate more like the the actual art
right 100 like with that trick he just
showed us you create this sense of
appreciation by revealing how complex it
actually was to achieve in camera that
there wasn't a trick that's the trick is
that there wasn't a trick yeah exactly
Alex is certainly a magician and I like
to think that I also create Magic in my
own way through images and one of those
tools I use to create images is
artificial intelligence so I figured for
today's sponsor Squarespace it'd be
really cool to do some magical AI image
generation Squarespace is an all-in-one
website hosting and creation service
that can let you build a website that
looks beautiful and Professional without
you knowing anything about building
websites so let's just check out a
Squarespace website building service
okay here's some examples the AI has
clearly been to squarespace's website
slash is showing you examples of the
kind of clean interface I'm able to
expect at the Squarespace website but
you know there's a bunch of great
feature Squarespace has an easy ability
to add video blocks to your web page so
you can embed videos from YouTube Vimeo
and a whole bunch of other places and
there I think video blocks look like
this the video blocks really look like
this nice clean way of showcasing video
on your web page you know what
Squarespace also has connected social
media accounts which lets you put things
that you post on Instagram or Twitter
Etc on your web page automatically if
you want to oh you're posting something
you don't want to go around and post it
like 10 times on all the different
platforms you're trying to service so
it's nice to have it automatically taken
care of for you here's what the AI
thinks that looks like
poop oh yeah look at these social media
accounts all connected there's zambly
and trust and luge
you know what if you are doing a bunch
of work on a website you might have
teammates Squarespace offers multiple
members contributing to one site if you
want to build a website with other
people multiple contributors
there they are look at they're all in a
zoom meeting wow they're all middle-aged
women now you might have these
award-winning templates and you might
have all these contributors but what
good is any of that if you can't track
your data in analytics you want to see
where people are going you want to see
which Pages they like the best so let's
see what traffic overview and analytics
looks like oh look at that
so this is kind of an accurate
reflection you know Squarespace gives
you all sorts of graphs and insights
into your data it's very very useful in
building websites so if you are
interested in building your own website
you can go to squarespace.com to get a
free trial once you are ready to
actually jump in and make the purchase
if you go to squarespace.com or crew you
can get 10 off all right back to Magic
so usually uh magicians when they find
cards they use slide a hand right
usually I wanted to try something
different with these cards though uh
what's your name Bud Austin Austin nice
to meet you bro Alex uh can you take out
any card from here
yep great great choice uh remember to
everyone and the camera as well
um I'm just going to place it back uh in
the middle right here so I'm gonna try
and not use my hand to find your card
I'm gonna do something else
[Laughter]
power of the Mind watch this I want you
to think of your card right buddy think
of it and watch this
what was your card the Ace of Spades
really yeah
seems like a lot of magic tricks are
built off these foundations of how to
start a trick or like you know control a
card or things like that and it's the
performance that you build around the
story that you build around it that
really makes it your own you can do the
most basic magic trick you know it
doesn't have to be hard at all you know
and it's going to be beautiful and like
you said it's how you bring it to the
table you know how are how are you going
to tell the story with that trick you
know let's let's put the cards away for
a sec
um so I've been fortunate enough as a
magician to meet amazing people right
like you guys obviously I've met a
couple of celebrities and I put a list
on my phone of celebrities I met and
didn't meet here I have an envelope with
an autograph of One Celebrity I did meet
so I'm just gonna place it actually can
you hold it for me right Griffin nice to
meet you Alex
um so on my phone I have a list with 100
different celebrity can you name a
number between 1 and 100 for me uh 57
are you 100 sure yes you want to change
your mind no please no okay 57 so here
watch notes can you go to a celebrity
for me please
can you scroll through make sure they're
all different also right
yeah those are all you got JFK's so
what's up
57 Mr Beast Mr B guys oh no
[Laughter]
if I have the autograph of Mr beasts
here I want you guys to go wild right
watch this we will regardless just like
only one piece of paper there's
literally one in there
to this
to Alex
Mr Beast
that's a signature
why 57 by the way it's the ketchup
number
[Laughter]
at a certain point boom reaction right
your mind as somebody who's constructed
these you know routines over and over
and over what is it that triggers that
hit and how do you make that as strong
as possible the Mr Beast effect I did
earlier right kinda mess with you guys a
little bit with his signature right it's
like all right that's just funny right
so it hits differently it's not a magic
trick now it's more like comedy right
somebody looking at me from a family
okay you know what guys I I knew I knew
this was gonna be a little bit weird so
I made sure to print his picture
you see the picture and it's like oh my
God so I think there's a level of like
you know it's like it's like a roller
coaster of emotions I think right you
have to put people in a certain like
state of of mine of like is it gonna
work
does he know what he's doing you know or
he's just like messing with us
I think so watching you do this stuff I
can't help but try to just figure out
how it works that's just how my brain
works you know like everything I look at
I'm constantly trying to figure out how
does that function so when I'm staring
at you do these impossible things the
fact that I can't understand it is very
frustrating so I can't help but guess as
to how you're doing it do you get that
often do people try to guess how you're
doing tricks yeah I mean I think it goes
with the with the job you know people
watching your stuff you just want to
enjoy it but you know I mean you want to
know how everything works which is good
you know it's your artistic brand and
your artistic mind that wants to
actually you know analyze everything and
uh how often do people actually guess
correctly and what is your reaction
almost never almost never yeah yeah and
and and the only reason for that it's
not because I do a I think I do a good
job of it it's more because their mind
is going to go so far you know they're
going to think about crazy methods
usually the actual method is way more
simple than what they think in our minds
yeah how about how about we do one more
yeah
um I'm gonna need two people for that
too um
Chris Chris all right and Matt Matt
what's up buddy Chris let's do it all
right
um say stop for me go ahead stop great
this is gonna be yours this is my very
if I see the card by the way we have the
uh King of Hearts go like this buddy and
okay cool and just place your Adrian on
top great and you're gonna do the same
thing say stop for me stop great it's
going to be yours all right hold the
deck for a sec great
um we have the king of hearts and the
three is Big Three Spades great here
watch this I'm just gonna
[Music]
take the corner of this yeah
amazing so here my goal is to place the
corner under a card for this the
guardian needs to pass through your hand
and through the card for real
yeah
no but wait wait if the corner is under
a card this guy said apart
go like this and look under the card and
show everyone that the corn is oh
[Music]
I think I know what happened the corner
needed to pass through your hand and
through the card right but I think the
corner got stuck somewhere
[Music]
no it can't be in there in the car
that's not how the reality works the
world doesn't work like this
make sure it's a perfect match too
is that it yeah
[Applause]
my Fitbit says that I'm working out
right now
you guys were amazing thank you so much
we just have to like go back to normal
now just go back to work yeah I guess
I think Ryan's good I think Ryan had a
good time yeah hey Ren what's your
favorite thing in the world magic
there you go
I'm glad you have turned my world around
today I am now excited again about life
in the future and Magic thank you thank
you Alex thank you so much for joining
us if you were at all inspired by the
stuff that Alex did with us today or you
want to learn how to do it yourself you
should go check out Alex's Channel
youtube.com Alex Boyer we'll have links
in the description on the screen there
is nothing better you can do for an
artist than to go check out their work
if you find it interesting so go check
out his channel well you know what
seeing you guys work together and
creating all of this world it's
inspiring really and it's so cool to see
magic visual effects practical effects
mixed together we have this hope you
guys enjoyed it and uh I'm gonna go home
inspired I'm actually speechless a
little bit man seriously like seeing all
of you guys working like this the whole
team and everyone is just that's magic
itself
oh that was cute
the real magic was hitting that
subscribe button no the real magic was
having a subscribe card pulled out of
the deck
well glad you enjoyed boys yeah thanks
for having me again
until next time